qui l'aurait cru donald trump qui
félicite macron pour la réussite du g7
en tout cas ça contraste avec l'année
dernière dans charlevoix puisqu'on se
rappelle cram palais jusqu'à renier sa
signature dans un tweet lors de la
déclaration finale cette année vous
entendez changement de ton le président
macron a réussi son pari mais comme la
semaine dernière frédéric mayrand
directeur du sirom était sur notre
plateau pour nous pister sur les points
surveillé je le reçois encore ce soir
pour voir si elle avait vu puisque les
bonnes choses vont se voir votre grille
caméra bonsoir alors on a quand même
trois sujets discussions taxer les
géants du web les relations etats unis
chine le nucléaire iranien
on vous laisse vous voulez bien nous
sommes d'accord pour dire que l'iran
doit respecter ses obligations
nucléaires doit avoir un comportement
responsable dans le golfe et travailler
avec nous mais au fond on a deux choses
très clair auquel nous tenons l'iran ne
doit jamais avoir l'armé nucléaire et
cette situation ne doit pas menacer la
stabilité de la région
est-ce que c'est l'élément clé la fin de
ce sommet 17e d'abord l'élément fort
c'est donald trump apparent presque
humble pendant presque tout le week-end
il faut dire aussi que emmanuel macron
avait eu la prudence de ne pas faire
rédiger de communiqué final pour éviter
justement la catastrophe de l'année
dernière à la malbaie donc pour éviter
que donald trump lui sans suite renier
sa signature par l'accent a été mis
effectivement sur l'unité et on a vu
donald trump qui sur des enjeux qui sont
chères aux européens mais cherche aussi
à emmanuel macron notamment
et les gars phare donc la fiscalité du
numérique accepté de discuter pour
l'instant en tout cas et accepter un
certain nombre de compromis par rapport
aux positions qu'il avait chez avant
d'arriver au sommet ça c'est aussi une
des caractéristiques du g7 c'est que ça
permet d'humaniser les relations entre
les dirigeants alors ça ne fonctionne
pas toujours avec quelqu'un qui a le
tempérament bouillant donald rock mais
ces germes en plus facile que si on
passe par par exemple la diplomatie de
twitter ici bien pris macron mais si on
parlait de l'iran en particulier parce
que sur les deux éléments on ne veut pas
que l'iran l arme nucléaire et on veut
pas que ça déstabilise la région et en
quoi ça c'est compatible avec les
entendre qu'ils avaient été signés
quelque chose au déchiré qu'est ce que
ça veut dire de la part de femmes face à
l'iran il serait même très rencontrer
essentiellement ce que donneront pas dit
c'est si les européens veulent continuer
la discussion avec les iraniens je ne
vais pas les empêcher de le faire
lui-même avait déchiré l'entente
essentiellement parce que c'était une
entente signée par son prédécesseur
barack obama c'était le principal
reproche qui lui adressait suite
cette entente les airs année ou au
déchirement de cette entente les
iraniens ont dit bah ce moment là s'il
n'y a plus d'entente n'y a pas de raison
que nous continuons à appliquer nos
obligations et là emmanuel macron est
venue rappeler avec les autres européens
que sur les points principaux il ya un
consensus au sein du car accidenté
c'est à dire que non l'iran ne doit pas
se doter de l'arme nucléaire là dessus
les pays européens et la france ont
toujours été très très clair mais en
même temps il faut ouvrir des pistes de
négociations avec l'iran et donald trump
a rappelé qu'il ne souhaitait pas
nécessairement un changement de régime
ce qui te rappelles quand même utile
pour ceux qui l'avaient peut-être oublié
ça contraste avec son conseiller bolton
qui lui aurait souhaité un changement
nous sommes d'accord et ont tous les
deux faucons sur cette question raison
blanqui encore derrière des sanctions
qui étrangle et l'iran où il ya des
sanctions qui seront de l'iran et que
les américains ont renforcé le mans en
niant leur propre signature dans cet
enfant est donc pour le moment que des
déclarations qui nous permet d'être
optimiste mais sans plus sur les rangs
absolument donc
le g7 de toute façon ce n'est pas un art
entre ce n'est pas un traité il n'y a
pas une pas les nations unies ça n'a pas
la force de droit ce sont des
discussions ouvert il a donc la lecture
la plus cynique ce serait de dire que
donald trump était plutôt d'humeur
agréable pendant le week end ce qui ne
veut pas dire que ça aura un impact dans
trois jours ou dans trois semaines
l'autre élément très important qu'on
surveillait d'ici ne serait ce qu'à
cause des discussions qu'on assure la
survie de nos médias c'est la taxe sur
le numérique la france est allée de
l'avant
qu'est ce qu'on comprend et y at il eu
ou pas entente entre les différents pays
ont sans bords s'en remettre en 2020
elle aussi dire en fait longtemps
qu'elle existe de manière presque
explicite depuis longtemps entre tous
les pays occidentaux autour de l'idée
qu'il faudrait trouver un moyen
d'imposer les géants du numérique qui
actuellement fait très très peu d'impôts
partout dans le monde sauf que la france
avait surpris les américains en dix ans
plus que les négociations
internationales n'avance pas
suffisamment vite nous allons imposer
nous mêmes les gaffes et donc les google
amazon facebook et apport sur le
territoire français ce à quoi le
président américain avait réagi en
disant c'est une taxe déguisée sur les
entreprises américaines
et si vous faites ça nous allons imposer
le vin français alors là il semble que
là la tension soit retombée un petit peu
la france 10 ans nous allons imposer la
taxe comme nous l'avons dit mais si nous
avons un accord en 2020 à ce moment là
nous nous retirerons cette taxe mais on
remboursera en plus les entreprises
américaines
adam chanteur et lui envoie pas donné
je ne sais pas la consommation de donald
trump mais effectivement mais c'est un
enjeu sur lequel en principe les
américains sont d'accord la polémique
est plutôt sur l'échéancier est ce que
c'est en 2020 est ce que c'est en 2025
on trouvera la solution et l'impact sur
les canadiens absolument parce que tous
les pays membres de l'osce et des font
partie de cette discussion là il est à
tous les états perdent de l'argent avec
la situation actuelle où les gaffes
parce qu'elles n'ont pas de présence
physique dans beaucoup de pays parce
qu'elles n'utilisent que les réseaux
sociaux internet finalement ne paye
presque pas d'impôts par rapport aux
grandes entreprises normalement sympa de
valentina part dit norma canadien dans
le cas canadien que je connais moins
effectivement ce n'est pas été on peut
dire au sommet
dans politique l'autre sujet qui a été
abordé mais est-ce que c'était la place
pour le faire la question avec la chine
après c'est aborder en pointe prince il
y aurait-il une accalmie de ce côté là
ou pas monsieur nacre ont pas voulu se
prononcer définitivement lâché n'est pas
d'application
oui autant l'iran était la surprise de
ce sommet du g7 qui ne devait pas
particulièrement porté sur l'iran avec
la venue du ministre iranien des
affaires étrangères
autant la fiscalité du numérique est un
peu ce qu'on craignait comme une source
de conflits qui est finalement plutôt
été une bonne nouvelle
la question économique a été du début à
la fin le principal enjeu de ce sommet
du g7
il ya un ralentissement économique en
chine et un ralentissement économique en
europe surtout en allemagne il ya des
nuages qui pointe à l'horizon sur
l'économie américaine et donc la raison
d'être du g7 depuis toujours depuis les
années 70 c'est de régler la gouvernance
économique mondiale donc c'était le lieu
pour parler de ce qui nuit en ce moment
aux perspectives de croissance et un des
facteurs importants c'est évidemment la
guerre commerciale entre la chine et des
états unis donc c'était un objet
discussion beaucoup de pays européens
ont demandé à trompe même si la chaîne
est absent quand une dame allongée 7
pouvez vous calmer le jeu un plus un peu
parce qu'en ce moment ça nuit à tout le
monde
trump n'a pas fait de grandes promesses
mais il a dit qu'il était prêt à
continuer les négociations avec la chine
pour éviter une augmentation des tarifs
mais là dessus il souffle le chaud et le
froid presque à chaque jour depuis le
déployer changer des pièces de même des
voyages du côté des républicains
commencent à s'inquiéter en disant
puisse être quelqu'un qui va peut-être
se poser à lui lors de primaires
républicaines peut-être générera pas
très loin mais diète trump est en train
de nous souhaiter
et oui les états unis dans une récession
et le monde est elle même dans une
guerre alors ça ça finit bien
aujourd'hui mais demain ça peut être une
autre journée avec trois sur tous les
ans jerry donald trump
mais c'est pour ça que des sommets comme
le g7 sont est il justement pour permet
quand même de créer un contact humain
entre entre les dirigeants qui l'espère
ton peu facilité
les choses un peu sur le long terme bon
vous vous y croyez mais les voix qui
s'élèvent en disant que c'est inutile ça
sert à rien ça ne change rien non mais
je pense qu'on peut se poser beaucoup de
questions sur ce genre de sommeil aussi
une mise en scène d'un théâtre politique
emmanuel macron était un maître dans
l'art de la mise en scène de ce sommet
qui était vraiment pour lui perçu ou
vendu comme une victoire personnelle un
grand médiateur sur la scène
internationale en même temps il est
assez évident que plus l'économie va mal
plus les défis sont grands plus il est
important pour les dirigeants de se
rencontrer et de parler parce que s'il
n'y a pas d'accord au sein du g7 qui
réunit en principe les économies qui
sont les plus proches et les démocraties
qui sont les plus proches
il est impossible d'imaginer un accord
au g20 qui est la version la plus large
et encore moins aux nations unies donc
oui je pense que c'est un lieu important
pour soi impulser des idées lorsque tout
le monde est d'accord soit moins réglé
ou parler des problèmes lorsqu'il ya des
désaccords un bref mot sur la
proposition pour sauver la forêt
amazonienne c'est mal reçue au brésil
qu'est ce que vous en faites vous êtes
pour ça ça fait partie des choses qu'on
annonce dans les sommets justement pour
montrer qu'il y à un accord donc il n'y
a pas d'accord sur les changements
climatiques
rappelons le de neutrons paie toujours
hostile à toutes les mesures visant à
lutter contre les changements
climatiques mais l'idée d'aider un pays
qui est aux prises avec un incendie
s'est pas s'il pourrait tenter un peu
pour tous les dirigeants de santé un
engagement commun et 11 ans de bonne
conscience merci frais d'éclairage
s'interdit rien ils ont plus merci à la
prochaine